Hey guys, it's Jan here!
Wasn't it tough spotting the easter eggs for
The Good Dinosaur at the cinema?
But now it's out on DVD, I've been able to
find 8 Pixar and Disney easter eggs and references
you probably missed when you first saw the
movie.
If you noticed any others, I'd love to hear
about them in the comments below.
And of course, as this is an easter egg video,
there will be some spoilers ahead if you haven't
seen the movie. So, if you're not ready for
that, check out my non-spoiler review of the
movie here.
Let's kick off with a big Pixar regular! A-1-1-3,
was a quite hard one to find, but you can
spot it on the fence when Arlo goes to feed
the chickens.
The A-1-1-3 easter egg has appeared in every
single Pixar movie to date and is a homage
to the classroom at California Institute of
the Arts where animation greats such as John
Lasseter and Brad Bird studied.
Hank from Pixar's upcoming movie Finding Dory
appears in the rock pool that Arlo falls into
after being bitten by a gopher.
You'll need to watch it very carefully as
when Arlo first falls in, the octopus's eyes
are closed.
By the way, in Finding Dory, Hank will be
voiced by Modern Family star Ed O'Neill.
There's a clever nod to Monsters University
character "Squishy" during the hilarious hallucination
that Arlo and Spot have after they eat some
rotten fruit.
Arlo and Spot float through the air, swap
heads and the five eyes which appear on Arlo
are a reference to Scott "Squishy" Squibbles
who was actually voiced by The Good Dinosaur
director Peter Sohn!
And you'll need eagle eyes to see this one
but during that same hallucination scene,
the Luxo ball actually floats by.
The Luxo ball originates from Pixar's very
first animation, a short film called Luxo
Jr, which features both the Luxo ball and
the two desk lamps, one of which appear in
Pixar's logo.
By the way, the hallucination scene also has
shades of when Dumbo and Timothy Q Mouse got
drunk on champagne, and started hallucinating
pink and multi-coloured elephants.
And Spot might be an ancestor of Finding Nemo's
Darla.
They both have a very similar shaped face
and eyes, freckles and a snub nose.
In Finding Nemo, Darla is called a fish killer
by other fish and interestingly the first
name that Forrest Woodbush, the Pet Collector,
comes up with for Spot is "Killer".
And in that naming scene when Forrest Woodbush
and Arlo compete to see who gets to keep Spot,
there are a whole bunch of shout-outs to other
Pixar characters.
There's Squirt, the playful turtle from Finding
Nemo, Frank the combine harvester from Cars,
Stinky Pete the Prospector from Toy Story
2, Violet, the daughter of Bob and Helen Parr
in The Incredibles, and Spike which is the
alter-ego for the slug-like employee Augustus
Jones at Monsters, Inc!
Oh, and by the way, Spike was also the real
name of the dog who played Old Yeller in the
classic 1957 Disney movie, which director
Peter Sohn has said was a big influence on
The Good Dinosaur.
When Arlo and Spot are running away from a
bunch of pterodactyls, they see what looks
like the silhouette of an adult Apatosaurus
in the distance, an easter egg for the Dinoco
sign in Toy Story, although as they get closer
they see the silhouette is actually made up
of two T-rexes.
And finally, this one was perhaps the toughest
to spot, but floating out here at the very
start of the film in the asteroid belt is
the Pizza Planet Truck itself!
The Pizza Planet Truck first appeared in Toy
Story and has made an appearance in every
Pixar feature film since then except The Incredibles.
So, guys which other easter eggs did you spot
in The Good Dinosaur? And do tell me which
is your favourite Pixar movie?!
If you enjoyed this video, I'll have another
easter egg video coming shortly for Disney's
Zootopia and you might also like to check
out these 25 awesome behind-the-scenes facts
about the making of Pixar's Inside Out.
As always, your likes, comments and shares
are hugely appreciated; and do please subscribe
if you want to see more videos like this.
Thanks for watching and see you next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!